Hey, what's going on? It's bill bird.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
January 29th, 2018 what's going on? Our y?
Yeah. Um, all right.
Well this was a board,
this would have been a boring
Sunday because there was, you know,
there's no football, right? They got
a, you got the week off in between the,
between the Super Bowl and
the championship games.
They had the pro bowl today,
which was kind of cool. Look like
football in the future where they would,
you know, they'd start to tackle somebody
and they're like, all right. All right.
All right. All right. All right. You know,
I don't know if that's the
concussion thing or the me too.
I don't know what it is.
He does not want you touching him.
Do not throw him to the ground.
I have a special guest to
liven up my Sunday there. Uh,
uh, Jesus sue one and only two
I'd rigs for Christ's sake.
Todd,
you are one of my favorite fucking people
in this business and you are one of my
favorite comedians. So is all
Azure. Do the appeal. The,
the feeling is mutual vendor or you don't
have to compliment me on this one of
my idols. Dude, you are. You
are the silliest fucking dude.
You make me feel mature. That's what
I like about you, Todd. Rex, okay.
Yes. Todd Rex who checks off a lot
of boxes in this day of caring.
That's right. You do. I don't
even know what that means.
I don't know what it means either.
I'm just trying to be progressive.
You would think that somebody would come
his fucking way and finally tapped a
magic wand on his head and make
something happen and say, Todd,
you've been destroying it at least
three times as hard as 10 times of the
fucking order or whatever. The math
is all the fucking comics out there.
I love working with you, but I hate
following you. He was a fucking murderer.
Finally,
this fucking asshole.
He got himself a special that he's taping
and it needs some people to come down
and then you can,
you know,
go on and I can open for you can make me
sweat a little there. No, no, not at all.
Right. He's going to be at the
satellite theater in silver lake.
Uh,
the satellite la.com for tickets.
That's all right.
Uh, February 11th, uh, you're going
to be doing the show. It's a Sunday,
but usually come out Dave, which
support the all right. Sunday,
which is a week after,
uh, the Superbowl. Right.
So everybody knows that was seven
30 and nine 32 shows, two shows,
two shows to show. So you're going
to go out there. You fucking,
you knocked the first one out
eagle. All right, I got it.
And then the next one you just go
off Cruze. Is that what you do?
What you do yours? He like dude, be
button of the first ones tightened up.
And then I spend the whole night trying
to forget that I'm taping one real and
stop trying to think like,
oh my God, I missed that tag.
Fuck. That needed to be
documented in the comedy universe.
I just try to look at it
like, all right, this is just,
I'm just documenting where my hour was
on this night and this is how it came up.
And I want you to do that because
every night when you go up there,
I don't know about you but I
mean I'm constantly fucking up.
Jokes are constantly leaving shit out
and then it adds to something else and I
never think of it.
Never think about it.
Like I never thought to get you a glass
of water before you sat here for fucking
hours. What an idiot. I'm going to have
to hit pause here in a minute. But um,
that's just how uh,
I had to do it that way just because
I want him to think about your,
I wanted to ask you about your thought
process cause I was curious. Um,
like I know that the night before
I'm going to be a wreck, you know,
just thinking about it and all the
funny guys, worry hacks, don't worry.
Acts are already fucking working
on their next hacky hour. Yeah.
They not even fucking nervous to just,
and they'll go off stage with this
shitty material and be like, dude,
I fucking crushed, crushed in every
funny guys. Like who is it? Good did,
it was terrible. I do
that every, every time.
I just really in a round about way
compliment to myself, I know him. Um, I,
you know, I got a waste to go. People
like, I don't know. She used to,
you're one of them. Did
Beasts. Um, yeah, so I, I uh,
someone told me,
I think Louis C k told me,
and I think you've heard this from
fucking bill Cosby. How funny is that? Uh,
you heard that, uh, you worked
this hard to get there. Um,
uh, don't forget to have fun, right?
So make sure, yeah. Cause if you don't,
haven't fun, that's going to be, you're
going to feel better about it afterwards.
If you have someone who
nitpicks at himself,
there's no way you're going to be happy
at the end of it. So just be forgiving.
Just be the fucking silly
fucking hilarious guy you
while you'll be fine. Yeah.
I'm not really too worried about it,
but I just want to make sure
that I already can tell you,
worry about it. You see,
you seem tighter than usual cheese will.
I'm doing your podcast.
It's kind of a big deal for me too.
I feel like it didn't the whole thing.
Now that you've peeked behind the curtain,
it's just me with a fucking
$99 mixer from good test ana.
We're sitting here on the counseling,
Ernie and Bert,
the all I did to prepare for you as I
turned on the AC and I squirted some
breeze. That's it. I know everybody
has these fancy fucking studios.
I just did a, I did your mom's house, uh,
with a Thompson girl and
Christina presents key.
I just did theirs and they
have this whole fucking studio.
Rogan has like literally like a
stern level studio. She's and um,
I should step it up at some point. Yeah,
it was, her house was dope. I don't know.
No one can see it. But your
house is dope. Oh, thank you.
It wasn't when I bought it,
but now that I've dumped all this money
into it and I could never get my money
back. Yeah, this is pretty good. I I,
this house was like almost a
hundred years old when I got it.
Almost 90 years old, I should say. Cool.
People live in here before though, right?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't want to talk about that though
because then people will fucking figure
out where I live.
I already have to fucking edit out
one of the comments you made earlier.
That will fuck.
Do people have fucking lunatics?
And that's what I'll tell you later.
It was just enough of something to make
some psycho just turn around and faces
speaker and start writing down
information. But I'm a paranoid dude. Um,
yeah. Anyways. Um, what
was I talking about?
What the fuck are we just talking about?
My add? I don't know. I have no idea.
You've been watching any hockey.
Did you see my Sean's elbow not to.
I was a thing of beauty. It was a thing.
It was so, it was perfect. Filthy. He,
he's, he got to trip. I know Eddie,
he's the size of Barney rubble,
so nobody paid.
He's not going to get called out like
all foods. Probably one of the worst.
But dude, he was, and I loved Marshawn
and I love the fucking Bruins,
but I love him. Come on. He's, but the
thing is, I don't like that aspect,
like doing that shit.
Did you see when a man destroy them?
Oh Dude, my God. Ah, that
was a brutal hit. Oh,
I thought he had like internal
bleeding after that cause he kept,
he kept skating but he kept skating.
Yeah. And he was just going like,
it seemed like beyond
the wit.
The thing about PK and,
well,
I'm so glad he placed her Nashville
not from Montreal anymore. It was,
he just as best as he used to.
He used to get us all the time and
everybody knew that was his move.
And I don't know why no one could see,
just knew exactly when your head was
down for a second. It was two crossovers.
He was inside and then all of a sudden
he was just in front of you. Right.
And he just ended your fucking life
for like, I dunno, like two shifts,
but um, yeah, I'm, I'm, uh, I always
liked that guy. I never take it to the,
to the point if there's a guy on a
team that I don't like, you know,
like when Derek Jeter played
for the Yankees, I couldn't,
I couldn't get myself to, to get to
the point of like actually hating them.
It's like the guy is great. Right? It
is good. Yeah. All you're saying is,
I wish this guy was on my team.
You have to watch some hockey watching
my son play hockey. He was a beast.
Of course. I know you
showed me all the, uh,
the video of them and he like picked it
up in to see who's like playing drums or
something. Right. They also play the drums
too and he plays drums. Any place hawk,
he chooses the kid's gonna be crushing it.
Would it get more legs than I am?
You're going to be a fucking grandfather
by the time this special comes out.
Jeez. Where you've been
working to uh, adjust. Uh,
I just flew back today from Phoenix. I
was with Craig Craig Robinson, you know,
been totally anthem for like a couple
of years now when he's not shooting
television shows, which is all the
fucking time that got works. Um,
so yeah. Uh, where were you guys working?
We were working at standup live in
Phoenix. Oh, okay. I know that place.
Five sold out shows. It was
fantastic. Had a ball. I did the uh,
you know what's fucking, that's fucking
nuts as far as like that downtown area,
how lively it is if there's
something going on. But the second,
the workday ends like during the week if
you're there like at five o'clock. Yeah.
It's fucking creepy. If the sons
don't have a game, it's over.
Yeah. I love it though. I mean, I
couldn't live there, I don't think,
but I have a really good time there.
Um,
I had a good time traveling with
you though when we went down south.
I was just like reading some comments
about the key, give me the keys.
Just give us the keys. Oh yeah, yeah. That
lady, I thought about that the other day.
We went to check in that hotel and
that lady was just fucking with the
instructions are, Jim is on the fourth
floor. It's open from nine to nine.
We, it's a continental breakfast,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I'm sitting there going like, oh
my God, how long is this going to take?
And she's in the middle of to go.
Did you just choose the key?
She got like offended.
She was bad for real
dude. I fucking was laughing
like I was in high school, man,
it was one of those labs.
So I was just like, oh.
Cause what it was was the fact
that she didn't find it funny.
It was already hilarious, but the
fact that she didn't find it funny,
it hurt her feelings.
She didn't have to deal with it.
And then she got mad all in
like fucking like half a second.
Then I felt like I was in class
again where it's like, oh my God,
don't start fucking laughing.
Or you're gonna,
you're gonna get like the tension or
something. Yeah. You also took me to that.
That fucking, uh, was at that
barbecue place to something.
Oh yeah.
What does it call it was it,
don't say the name of it
cause it was terrible.
Well what the first ones we went through,
then we went to the,
when we went to that,
we went to that one where it was a
giant fucking place and they had like 40
fried murder chickens that you can see.
You don't remember that place?
It was gigantic. You know all my God,
this place is fucking unbelievable.
That the place where you ate.
And then we went to the Nascar track and
then you were like TRX wishing you had
a salad.
Oh
was that in a Charlotte?
That was Charlotte. Okay.
And we did the Nascar experience.
That was very cool though.
So let's talk about crossing it.
That dude who was driving us
around is 20 years old named Dylan.
I know anyways as much as a jockey because
he doesn't want to slow the car down.
I couldn't believe what like what a piece
of shit or race car it looks like when
you walk up to it.
I've seen formula one cars up close.
They look like absolute like it looks
like if you stepped on it the whole thing
would fall apart cause all it is,
it's just,
it's just an engine suspension and
tires and everything else is just the
lightest. Did you see the uh, the, the
gas pedal, we shouldn't have like a stick.
It was like a bent coat hanger.
It's like real,
it would have like if you had
like that just the floor thing,
whatever that the pedal is
to rest your foot on it,
we'll be able to have that in there.
That's the difference between you like
guess winning the race or a coming in
like third row because that fucking thing
sitting there with a piece of rubber
that's in the way
that race that actually there um,
NASCAR is not doing well it's not,
the numbers are down. No. When I
went to the Daytona 500, they'd,
they'd painted the seats
like every other seat.
Like they had like three colors and they
would paint them the big it look like
this people in the season. Yeah.
Well, cameras flying by and you know,
used to have it like that
was the Minnesota north
stars used to have seats like
that and I thought it was cool and now
I'm thinking well maybe cause nobody
showed up for the game and maybe
that's why they moved to Dallas.
So when I hear all those Minnesota North
Star fans still complaining that their
team left,
I mean if there was people that well
there was people there I wouldn't have
noticed. Right, right,
exactly. You would've been able
to see the season.
I don't even know how to skate.
None thousand lakes say you
watching either football, was that,
do you watch any of the football?
I haven't been,
I haven't Washington the football,
the only thing that I like of the
Washington Redskins and they're terrible
number one on the street from Baltimore
hosts. How'd you become a Redskins fan?
On and off from silver spring,
Maryland,
right over the DC line and let
people are thinking bout, okay,
but you know I had grass and it
shouldn't my yard and two cars.
Both parents or I'm not saying that
that's not available at Baltimore.
What people think of the wire and the
corner when they think about Baltimore.
But that's not where I lived.
That's why,
cause that's where I met you.
I met yet the Baltimore Improv
with that fucking debt long.
He had walked down like that
three quarters of a mile hallway,
the last mile or whatever. Yeah. That
was the worst location ever for a,
uh, for a, for a fucking
comedy club when he club there,
I was all thrilled they'd let me come
down there and they asked me if I wanted
to close out the Sunday one time because
somebody canceled and that was all
fucking excited. And I drove there from
New York City to do it and I was like,
I'm going to get in with the Improv.
And I showed up and there was like 10
people there and the owner talk was
talking to the broker,
never talked to me and then
walked out while I was on stage.
And I remember being on stage.
I think I knew when I was on stage cause
I was kind of glancing over like, okay,
well it's, that works at
Sonic Burger. Um, man,
it was deaf.
It's really fucking annoying.
I don't know why anybody who ran a club,
why the fuck you would ever do that?
Because you don't know who's coming
down. Right. And for all you know,
they're going to go on, you know, and,
and do something. The fact that she would,
I was driving down from me,
he didn't even say thanks.
Classic fucking club managers, the
fat, big 50 inch fucking waste,
you know what I mean? But those
slacks, that giant fucking belt,
well, the Gaberdine, whatever
they're called. What are those flags?
Call action slacks.
Yeah, the action slacks. He uh, yeah,
I ran into a number of those fucking
people. That's my big thing though.
This should I, do you
know what? I'm turning 50.
Are you really turned it five zero
to 49 in May. You do all right.
They're young stuff.
You want to know what the next year
you life's going to be like? I, uh,
hopefully it's going to be
something like yours. No. Well,
I've decided that I'm going
to, uh, I'm going to fucking
get myself that. Like, rather
than looking at 50 would dread,
which I'm really not
considering it. I, you know,
so many of my friends and fucking died
then even make itself. I was, you know,
they'll record it in DC. Don't tell
me he died. I swear to God. No,
we didn't see did it last weekend.
Last Linda, he fucking died.
What?
Um,
there was like some Carter cardiac event.
What are those friends was like coming
from Connecticut going down to Florida.
Hadn't seen Joe in like 15 years.
Stopped by his house and they were
going to go to the Improv to watch, uh,
Lavelle Crawford and Joe said he had
a headache and one upstairs or take
something like aspirin or whatever it was.
I sat on the bed and like laid back
and crows while his buddy was there.
That he hadn't seen it.
15 years.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
Oh my to that guy had one of my favorite
fucking jokes were about the current
food.
No,
the jokey did when he was having
unprotected sex with a woman.
And you know, he goes, I'm doing my thing
and I'm doing my thing. She goes, Joe,
don't you come and me,
don't you come and meet y'all job.
Goddamn you don't come at me. And
he goes, I blocks all that out.
Yeah.
Zola's hilarious.
I haven't seen him in fucking,
I haven't seen him in like 15 years.
There's going to be a GS.
Ah,
fuck
yeah. What we're getting at that age where
people are just dying. And I was like,
you know what's really fucked
up is I know you want to do.
Since the time that I don't, it's not
even like shocking to me anymore. Yeah.
I mean like what I hear now,
I used to be like, oh my God.
But I was at my son's hockey game when
someone called me and he was like, Yo,
Joe record died. I was like, you serious?
And he's like, yeah, I want to know how.
And he's like, I don't know.
I'll find out. And I was
like, all right, call me back.
I'm on my son's hockey game.
Well have years ago,
I know what it is,
is the first wave that goes is,
it's usually a be bad genetics,
bad luck or bad diet.
And then after that it's like if you
had half a bad diet, half bad genetics,
just literally like when the
grim reaper is going to get you.
So speaking of that, becoming
a dad at this point, like
I was fucking old as I am.
I got it. You know, I've cut back
on the booze and, and uh, so I'm,
I'm trying to get myself
down to my fucking, uh,
to my fight and wait and actually maybe
get a personally you look fit. Yeah. I, I,
I,
I took four months off of booze and then
for the last month I've been drinking
like lightly,
but I dunno,
I think I'm just too old now because I
took those fucking four months off and
now going back to it, just, I get to,
and then I drink too and I'm just
like bagged up the next day. Um, so,
I dunno, I think I'm going to go,
I was joking that I'm going to go,
I'm going to be like staying in my 50
just to like fucking pilates and yoga and
tantric sex.
Try to learn how to come for 40 minutes.
That's how a lot of his music is.
His recorded blood.
People don't know that when a,
it's actually him coming in the
beginning of a synchronicity. Is that it?
Whoa.
That's him. That's him. Record them.
And I recorded my favorite
corner bag and his wife. Right.
For the first 40 minutes.
Then the last five minutes he just
sings this song and right as he comes,
that's the,
okay.
Yeah.
Gordon Gordon. So Gordon
Commoner there, Jeez.
I saw him at a, I saw him at the Hollywood
bowl with Elma, said Gaylord Perry.
It's a WHO's the guy from genesis that
sank? Sledgehammer. Peter Gabriel.
They're real. Yes. Yeah, they both were
fucking awesome. And they had like an,
I was like, all right, who's
gonna? Who's gonna open,
who's going to fucking clothes?
And they just,
one would sing a song and then the next
one come out and sing a song and then
they would just bolt out there and if
there was the other person saw and they
would just sync back up.
Oh yeah,
that's still Peter Gabriel had like
synchronized dance moves and shit.
It was fucking Vin and then they were bad.
But that was part of the joke.
But you just see was he
didn't give a fuck late.
It was like two guys like daughter plays
with them too sometimes. Is that right?
There's like the violin and she
comes out and crosses on the violin.
I'm trying to remember
if he had a violinist.
I just know that he was just like
the guy just aged and said fuck it.
Or I was staying was you know,
still in shape and shit.
So pdf data look terrible now dude.
He came out looking like that headline
headliner that didn't make it.
It just doesn't give a fuck anymore.
Comes out with like wearing like the
same sweat suit he was wearing when you
pick them up at the airport, just
walks on stage. Maybe you put a hat on.
He had to be at a but big ones that you on
staying always has one of those fucking
those clothes that looks like he's going
to do a,
what was that movie he did with the Tina
Turner where she shaved the side of her
head. Oh, my Thunderdome. Thunderdome.
I feel like he got a bunch of clothes
from that movie that still fit them right.
He still has the trailer, the
wardrobe trailer, all that Mesh,
Spiderman looking shit,
flashy underwear peeking out of the back.
Shane Shane Mill cert.
Well, I saw those guys.
They fucking, they absolutely killed
it here. I've got to make sure what,
20 minutes. Then at some point I do have
to read a little bit advertising, but um,
through who's just fucking Internet
provider ATNT mine is just,
it's just not happening for me here.
I think I might,
I don't even know who I have.
Nia handles that and it's,
it's just been on the Fritz. I gotta
drive on the, Fritz has been on the Fritz.
I've got to drive over to
Starbucks, buy something, stomachs.
I don't drink coffee. All right. I mean I,
I guess stick the coffee has to be amazing
line strong as it is it because you
don't need to be cafe.
Oh, I know. I don't know.
Worse wired is all I'm the worst dude.
I, I need like the reverse of that.
But you go into all of that food,
just socks,
all of their food just fucking
sucks. All right, let me,
let me read a little advertising
here. Um, how much, how much,
how much time are you going to do when
you special? I'm doing an hour. Hour.
That's it. Do you know, maybe a
little longer so we can cut it down.
All do as little as I would do like
whatever you, you want it to be.
I would only do a little bit
more than that. Yeah. Cause yeah,
it makes your life so much easier for you.
If you want to do an hour special,
dueling an hour and 10 or then usually
just lift a bit or to the same guys that
are uh, shooting want special shot
on the Evans special. That is, uh,
they said that, uh, the owner,
they're like an hour and 20 minutes and
that they wanted to cut it down to an,
because showtime wasn't buying an hour,
20 minute specials.
They were just buying our semester. Then
you've got to start killing your babies.
That's the worst.
But he refused to cut it and so
they just took it as an hour and 20.
So if you watched the special, this
on right now is on showtime right now.
It's an hour and 20 minutes.
Jesus on yams telling the business
which way it's going. Wow. Call this.
I would have been like, all right, I'll
cut it down. All right. Oh look, all zip.
Talk about the challenge of
finding great talent. Well,
usually I have a hack on here, but this
week I've found Todd rex. Thank you.
I found you on zip recruiter.
I looked up hilarious guy shooting
his special and fucking silver. Like,
all right.
Ziprecruiter knew there was a smarter way.
So they built a platform that finds
the right job candidates for you.
Ziprecruiter learns
what you're looking for,
identifies people with
the right experience and
invites them to apply to your
job. Uh, if read by the wrong person, this
would seem really racist. Whitman. Yeah.
Um,
these invitations have revolutionized
how you find your hire.
In fact, 80% of the employers
who post on the g on sip,
Hey,
get a quality candidate through the
site and just one day you got to do
something interesting or
they won't listen to it.
And Zip recruiter doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest
applications you receive.
So you never miss a great match.
The right candidates that are out there,
a zip recruiter is how you find them. A
business businesses of all size, trust,
sip,
okay.
Uh, for using their higher needs.
See now you're doing now, right now,
my listeners can try ZipRecruiter
for free. That's right. Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bird.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr
ziprecruiter.com/bird
the smartest way to hire.
Oh, Jesus. Look who's here,
but up, up, up. Mandy's brds.
No more sweaty balls. Mandy. Mandy's.
You could buy him at the fucking mall.
I'm on my podcast with Todd rex.
See Shooting the special.
What the heck?
Go down and get yourself some fucking
tickets and your balls will feel great and
these underwears. All right, you
want to look good? Fake Todd,
do you want to look good
with your significant other?
I do. This Valentine's Day.
You want your fucking junk to be sliding
around so silky smooth shit in the
checkout me undies matching pairs.
Would you ever do this with
you as a unique, fun gift
for you and your Valentine?
Did the perfect balance of comfort,
fit and exciting prints?
Don't spend another Valentine's
Day giving the same old gift.
Checkout me undies.com find the
best match for your match beyond.
These are the most comfortable and fun
undies you and your significant other
will ever own that made from
the softest materials on earth.
We're talking three times softer than
cotton and I believe that at this point
because the cotton,
the lobby has never debated this fetus
for students right out of the fetus.
I heard that that they dip in organic
dyes so it doesn't give you ball cancer.
This Valentine's day gets your platinum
a gift. That's for the both of you.
Order by February 5th at 10:00
AM for free standard shipping.
So your gift arrives in time.
Matching pairs of fun, thoughtful,
comfortable gift. They're going back in.
They should have ended it right there.
It's a comfortable gifts you share with
your significant other 100% satisfaction.
Guarantee me undies guarantees you and
your significant other will love your
matching Paris or your money back. You
know what they should do next year? Four,
they should have everybody,
whoever sends in the cutest picture,
a picture of them and their
own and they're matching pairs,
gets a free tip trip to matching Paris.
Oh No.
God matching pair is
nothing to get your 20% off.
That was just an idea of people.
That's not an actual offer.
So don't fucking sent people in with
your gut with the spare tire hanging over
your sill. John's there a long Johns. Um,
to get you 20% off your
matching pair of free shipping,
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
that's [inaudible] oh, sorry.
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible]
that's Mandy's dot com slash burnt.
This will be the best Valentine's
Day gift that you will give.
Start matching your bottom
half to your top. Better half.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr right
now pair of all promotional here they
gave me. So there. Yeah. Did you
Rocco? I definitely want but they,
they definitely, they gave me the
Greg Louganis cut one of them.
That was the west end is the
one, you know, don't uh, the,
the West Hollywood cut
there. So I, I was not in a,
I was not in gay male shape when I
got him, so I did not look good. I'm,
while I'm trying to get it in as good
as shape as those fell is down there.
But uh,
who used to have the pit like that?
I want to get in shape now
I want to get engage shape
cause I had a buddy of mine,
all he does is he just loses like fucking
10 pounds and then he just sorta push
us down his shirt, go and do it. I
looked good. You know, you're like pat,
you stomach. I think. I think I'm looking.
All right. Um, do you and your wife,
do you guys, uh, do you guys,
uh, four kids? Of course we do.
Do Two guys, you guys celebrate
Valentine's Day? Is there at this point,
how long have you guys been
together? Since 95. That's great man.
You 23 years,
but it took me till 2004 to tie the knot.
Oh yeah.
Would it make sure she was the one so many
years? Is that like 10 years ago, man?
Wait, 2001 2004 2004.
So that's a nine years.
Oh by all right. It took
me what it was, dude,
it took me nine years to really
the fuck. Yeah. Yeah. Stupid.
I knew in nine months, but I was
just like, I don't know. Right.
And then also my wife was a little bit
of a commitment phobe we're both like
commitment phobes yet totally
relationship people. So it totally worked.
You know what I mean?
Right. So He'd lived there,
her whole sid and Nancy fucking lifestyle
for a while, you know, not married,
no kids party.
And had a great time.
We did that for a while when
it hit all the water parks,
the matching t shirts. Oh
yeah. Matching me undies.
It took me forever to propose to her,
but I tell you why it, why it happened.
I went to a party with friends of mine
one night and I ended up spending an ad
out in Virginia and I was on my way
back the next day, like 10:00 AM. Uh,
my wife was furious.
She was my girlfriend at the time.
We were living together and she
was furious and she called me.
She already left me a message and I
checked the message and then she called me
again when we were driving home. And so
when I picked up the phone and say, Hey,
I was just was out here thinking with
my friends. The reason I was like,
I'm out here with my friends
and spending the night.
It's like I was talking
to a man, I think, uh,
I think I'm ready to
settle down in Mariya.
Wow.
Was she that you had to come up with that?
She know that she better because, well,
she will now when she listens to this.
No Way, dude, I want to get you
in trouble. So what did she do?
Was that she was like really
good. I did want to have a fight when I
got home for, for spending the night out.
So yeah. So that defused the
whole like fight those coming up
and set you up for another thousand
more in the next year there.
Um,
I,
I just want to fuck did I do
and I finally just realized,
uh,
I just knew she was gonna leave
it Sundays off the pot. No, it was
some days when I was mad at her.
I would fantasize about breaking up,
but even in the fantasy of her
breaking up when she would walk out,
even in the fantasy of that, I would
still go, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It sounds like all right. I got
to make, oh yeah, that's, that's,
that was the,
Paul Versey helped me get through that.
Paul Versey has actually helped a
number of comedians get over that.
Like, uh, that's, that's thing, you
know, you think it's a mountainous,
you just stepping up on the
curb, which just like, dude,
where are you going? Right?
What do you do? You know,
she's going to be so happy.
You're going to be happy once you get
through the fucking vows and all of that
bullshit. Then you just said a party with
all your friends and is fucking great.
He was, he was 100% 100%
fucking right. So, um,
I was gonna ask you,
do you guys go out on Valentine's
Day and now we don't really sell it?
[inaudible] I'm going to chocolates
and I'm like that or carbs, you know,
we might, you know, we have the kids,
so a lot of the times we're just a,
we'll wait till the kids go to sleep
and then we'll have a bottle of wine and
watch a movie or something downstairs.
Some corny like that. That's way better.
We're going out and go out to
dinner. Like, dude, we're so old now.
Sometimes it feels like a,
we want to go out and have a good time.
So we're gonna like we're gonna go out
to dinner and then go into Hollywood and
get some drinks and maybe go to a dance
club or whatever that by the time we're
done eating dinner late, do
you want us to go home? Uh,
and it's a how to you when
the other person says that
there's this like, yes, yes,
I do. Just want to go, I don't want to
go to Hollywood right now. Yeah. Like I,
I for years would rather drink at home.
I got better stuff here.
Then they got out at the bar.
They always have some shit stuff and
another rape you or the praise also. Yeah.
And once you're with the person
you're going to be with that,
they got the worst booze. I'm not
interested in meeting anybody. Right.
So all I'm going to do is go out there
and then I got to deal with like,
how am I getting fucking
home? This is before like Uber
and all that Shit. I been,
I been drinking at home the for,
for years or something.
He was like, yeah, we have what?
Bourbon or I have bourbon,
whiskey, Tequila. Yeah.
There's really smokey I think whiskey,
one time I was here,
that was probably a scotch. Scotch.
Yeah, it was good. Yeah, it was good. Oh,
did we smoke cigars? Uh Oh no, no,
I don't think we did because
that's how I was thinking.
My daughter just had her first
birthday and I was looking at,
at the house that do that, we had
like 16 kids over here. Really all,
I have friends who had kids and that,
cause you know, once you have a kid,
all your friends who don't have kids,
it's just like they keep live in their
rock star life and you're like, you just,
you get like six more calls like I, and
to watch the kid. And he did. He just,
he just fade out and started, you
know, they start disappearing. Horizon,
you just fade out.
Uh,
like that band member who's on
the first album and he was like,
whatever fucking happen that
can, and then they, you know,
they never see that guy until like the VH
one behind the music. He's just so, oh,
I am. I even know it.
Putting out a second album.
They just didn't have a call me and all
of a sudden I was just like, all right,
get some out. Um, yeah.
So I was looking around the
living room and we had like,
like 16 little kids and their ages.
The forward encounter it.
Yeah. And just like toys Galore,
just shit all over the place.
And I was just looking,
thinking like, you know,
18 months ago this would
have been five of my friends.
We would have been getting shit faced
watching the game and smoking cigars and
just how, like how much it changes
in a good way. Like we went to the,
went to the park today for the
first time I went over, I put,
I put her on the swing and
shit. She loved it. Oh yes.
Squeeze mentally greatest clex was a video
of that man because I know it goes by
so fast and you'll look back at those
pictures with a tear in your eye. Oh,
I know. No, I'm already doing it.
I'm already like this a part
of me that's like uh, uh,
as psyched as I am to be a dad there,
there was a mild depression with
her turning one row going like, ah,
she's not a baby anymore man.
She's a tod of next year.
She turns to her age have doubled
in a year. Yeah. She's all,
but I see why people keep having babies
cause you just want to keep hitting
reset. Right. Cause
it's so fucking awesome.
And I like talking in a positive way
about it because when my wife got pregnant
just so many people said all this
negative shit and like all dual,
you know boys league. It's over for you.
Yeah. No more getting low cause he blood.
No, we'll going to Thailand
seeing what's up over there.
Like I'll this degenerate shit.
And I was just like, yeah,
this is way better than
that shit though. Yes, no.
Today we were over there
and I was just like, uh,
I was having the best time and I, you
know, it was, yeah, it was quite good.
Clean Fun is actually getting a
little bit of exercise, um, clean.
And she kind of took her first
step in the park, which was cool.
And uh,
so yeah.
So now have you figured out what the
motivation tactic was to get it going
through it? I see. I'll tell you
what's fucked up though, was Imani,
that is the definition of organic in
the deaf in the dictionary versus the
definition of organic
within the food industry.
Like they literally changed it
like with law, what organic means.
Cause I know when,
when we're given her like poison shit
cause she's fucking so excited to eat it.
Like no, no, no, no, no.
The shit that they call it organic, but
it's really got like fucking this, like,
like they try to get you addicted to it,
like cigarettes,
the same fucking thing.
So we had these little puffs
that said organic on them and uh,
I just noticed that like,
we would have like really good food and
she would start pointing at the yellow
ones, like a lab rat. And
then one time I went to reach,
just reached for the can and she
started like hopping up like, yeah man,
give me a hit. So yeah. So,
um, yeah, we phased those out.
I'm actually, that's not true. We
have, we have one more can down,
so we're going to wean her off
and then, you know, she's a kid,
so like she doesn't see it. She's not
going to be thinking of them. But, um, I,
that's the thing that's, uh, that
can also drive you nuts is uh,
that type of shit.
And then if you have any sort of a
friend with a kid in your life that is
totally up on all these issues, and
then they just, they just come to you.
It's like a fucking,
it's like this cloud of
fear that they just dump on.
You go to this website,
you have to fucking,
but we have friends like that, or at least
a couple in, they're fucking annoying.
And it's like,
and even though our kid likes their kid,
we have to like cut them back a little
bit. I'm like, my daughter was like, well,
what did she coming over? And I'm like,
if the kid comes over that's fine,
but I can't have the parents
come over here to like,
did you get your kids vaccinated?
How do you handle that?
Because that's what I realize now is
that you can have like you can be friends
with people,
like a couple of you and your wife are
friends with a couple and then all of a
sudden,
and they have kids but you don't have
kids so you're not dealing with them on
that level.
But then when you have a kid,
the relationship changes now you not
only do you guys have to like get along
socially when you go out, you know, you
both vibe, you got to kind of on site,
they gotta be within your wheel house
of how they raised their fucking kid.
And if the kid comes over
and he's a fucking lunatic,
like brighten the dog and shit, like
going to what? What is this caveman?
You got to kind of be like,
I don't want my kid acting like that.
Right. No, we have a,
I'm not saying any names cause I don't
want to alienate any people that might be
listening to this,
but we have one family who has a kid
that's just fucking rude and I can't have
it and I just, I cannot stand. But my,
my kid wants this kid to come over
and always like, Jesus Christ,
should we let just fucking kid come over
and then like maybe they changed over
the last six months and they come spend
the night and it's a fucking nightmare.
What are the rules
if a kid comes over and he's rude,
like what can you say
now to a fucking kid?
Did I started just getting serious with
all I do. Go back to bed. Go back to bed.
So fucking waking up every 10 minutes
and calling for your mommy and then I'm
gonna call your mommy. No, no,
don't call my mom. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. I'm like,
then do, what the fuck are you doing?
I don't call him say fuck no, no,
cause I don't know how I'm not going
to be, I mean lending shut the fuck up.
You being a fucking asshole. Right. So
being a little asshole. No, I'm just,
I told my wife, am I doing, he gets up
one more time. I'm not talking to him.
You've got to talk to him cause
I'm gonna Start Getting Mad.
Do you remember back in the day, like if
your friend's Dad said anything you will
afraid of, right? Yeah. Hell yeah. Go
back to the room and go to bed. Like,
Oh shit, this motherfucker
serious and it needs to come down.
I hate that they call me by my first
name tied. No, they don't said Todd,
I'm scared. Can you call my mommy?
I'm old school. I'm old speech.
He had called me mister, right.
That it let me fuck a bill.
Bill.
You got wait, what's to eat here? Right,
right. No Dude. I would literally be like,
what the fuck did you say to me?
You Little Shit. I won't say that,
but that's what I'll be thinking.
So that course, as I say,
please address me as Mr Bur the subutex
he will hear is what the fuck did you
say to me? You Little Shit. And then
he'll say to his mother and yeah, you
right. Yeah this one get a little girl
comes over to our house and she was like,
she'll come downstairs,
I sleep in all morning and then come down
to the kids who were my wife and I are,
my daughter's still asleep and she'll
come downstairs before everybody and she
be like, what? What's for
breakfast? And my wife was like,
well you know pancakes and sausage. She
was like, yeah, I don't like that stuff.
What else is there? And my wife
just looks at me and he's like,
this is a bit serious right now.
Like go the fuck back upstairs.
Yeah.
What the fuck out?
Oh I would love to hear a kid
now he's saying to my mother,
my mother would just be, well that's
all there is. I guess. You know,
I'll talk to you at lunch.
My wife's,
the boss says,
I guess he'll just be hungry then
cause that's what we're having.
And if you're in, if you don't either,
just going to be hungry. It's amazing.
I would like,
some of these kids are rude to sit and
you say something to the parents were
like, yeah, she's a little
crazy. She's like, no,
now that's, that's like when people have
a dog that's fucking nuts. Like I did,
but I, I quarantine the thing when people
would come over except one time I got a
little confident and watch to me the dog.
Whisperers and then my friend had
getting bit j law had got bit by my dog,
bit him on his calf GIM a nip.
Um,
yeah, that dog scared the living shit
out of me. One time we were downstairs,
she was in a cage. Oh yeah. That
doesn't notice. He was a nerd.
I was like walking past,
not the case with the battle of the cage
will scare the fucking piss out of the
whole point.
God cage of the Darby shredded right now.
Yeah. She was a, an adorable hell hound.
She loved the hell out of me and
about six people and everybody else.
She treated as a fucking intruder.
And, uh, I would just, you know,
it was the smartest, most painful, uh,
decision I ever made, but I didn't
understand, uh, that I was still going,
like I saw, you know, the last two
days in a row, she's in town. Uh,
it's good that you keep it, like you've
kind of still take care of her in a way,
right? Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah,
definitely. It's kind of like,
and I get pictures of her
all the time and when,
like once every two months she'll
come to town and I just take for,
for a hike every single day like this.
You remember your legs the opposite way?
She did. And she does. She
does. And, uh, if, when I,
when I go out to where the guy lives,
if I show up, she's kind of look,
cause she's not used to seeing me down.
You know,
first they see the shape
and it's the smell,
like the whole way the dog
brainworks or whatever. And then, um,
then, you know, then she's all
back to normal and everything.
But I gotta tell you,
I was nervous meeting her
because of the way she was,
because I knew at that point she had
bonded with the new person and it might
view me as like a threat. I mean
the dog was like, dude, that dog it,
my buddy said that there, uh, as
cleo forsee yeah. Verse he goes to,
this should be a 30 for 30 on that dog,
that dog's life.
Like how it was abandoned by the La River.
I mean,
so many times this thing should
have just been like, you know,
like whenever the Olympics come around,
they always have like those crazy stories
that make you tear up all the shit
that they went through.
Like he could do that. Yeah.
And Dyke as a pitbull be in that
big of a pain in the ass like that,
those things, if those things sneeze, they
get put down, it's fucking terrible. But,
um, the fact that she's still
like living this awesome life, uh,
makes me feel good. And every time I see
her, like, um, you know, the dude of God,
it was my former trainer.
So, uh, and he, he just like,
she has her first dog friend now.
Every dog, she tried to murder.
Now she's like friends with the dog,
but like they needed like his
level talent, like as he says,
jokingly said, yeah, I've,
I've been slow cooking her.
She's not someone that you
like, okay, this is how it is.
And then boom to that and it's just
been this year long thing that she's now
finally ready to just end.
Even when he started hanging,
she started hanging out with another dog.
There was this whole fucking process
that he had to go through and,
and totally keep an eye on my dog because
my dog does this shit where like when
she's going to attack, she's in
the cage. Wow. She did that shit,
but she was out in the open. Um, she just
made the decision. There was no ground.
There was no warnings going wrong.
She just did it. She just, she had,
she would just fucking do it.
Let me read 'em let me read some of
the questions here. All right. Um,
taught by the way, you're gonna you're
kind of fucking, I can already tell, Dude,
you're already wound up about this thing.
You're going to fucking murder dude.
Thank you.
I'm excited about it. I really am. Yeah.
I feel like this is like, you know,
I've been doing this shit for so
long and I'm at the age right now.
Like if it doesn't fucking
pop for me right now,
it's not going to fucking happen.
Nah, that's, that's the old dude.
That's the old way of thinking.
You're totally in control,
right?
I do this business like it's a giant mall.
Okay.
And I have my little store in the
mall and you walk into my store, hey,
how you doing? I tell jokes, I
do a podcast kind of cartoon.
See anything you like. That's what I'm
selling. If you don't fucking like it,
I get it. See you later. But when I
first got into this business, I would,
you know, it's like you're
walking around the mall. Oh,
we've to this selling shirts. I
got to sell shirts. Oh Fuck Day.
They get sneakers I got to be doing.
You try to like do whatever with
the Joneses. Yeah. Fuck that too.
Just the way your cartoon is fucking
Hilarious, man. Oh, thank you.
Frank Murphy and a and vicar.
My two very guys. Oh yeah.
You went to the UAE to see you wait for
the third season where we're editing,
editing like feeds.
It's going to be out later on this year.
I'm not allowed to say exactly when,
I don't have an exact date either,
but like Netflix has like,
you know,
they don't like the fucking geniuses
of this new thing as they, they,
I remember the last time
like, well last time, uh,
when I had a special coming out there,
they wanted me to come in to meet
with them to like talk about,
discuss promoting it. And
I'm thinking like, what the
fuck are we going to discus?
Throw up a couple of billboards.
I'll talk about my podcast, do it.
I went in there,
it was like bill Belicheck shit.
I can't even, I can't even explain
it. Like I went in there going like,
this is ridiculous that this is just an
idiot like me with a bunch of Dick Jokes.
And then I just,
I,
I watched them breaking down to how
they were going about promoting it.
Like two people who are watching Netflix
and they're fucking algorithm and all
of that shit judged by what
you watched and all that shit.
Not saying it's a perfect
system. It, it blew my mind.
Fucking blew my mind.
They didn't know it doesn't do,
there's a reason why they're
global right now. Uh,
and it's not from hanging out with me
then. Alright. A peach cobbler recipe.
Hey Billy crust king. I like to bake by
the way. Really? Yeah. I mean my daughter,
he told me that before I made
my daughter a birthday cake.
I'm doing that every year of a life.
Are you doing the non GMO with the no
gluten than non tasty for Austin? Oh No.
There was a bunch of sugar and fucking
cell phone talk yet. Baby seals in it.
That's a big politically incorrect
cake. Um, all right, dear Billy,
Chris King, I'm invited to a
Superbowl party. By the way,
you know the Patriots are
in it again this year.
Do you realize if Tom Brady w
gets another ring? Jesus Christ,
him and Bill Belicheck we'll have more
rings than every franchise in the NFL
except for the Pittsburgh
Steelers. There'll be tied. Wow.
And then their entire 50 years,
50 something years of every
franchise trying to win one.
Did Brady doesn't lose
though, just letting you know
that, right? No. Uh, yeah,
he does. He loves twice to the giants.
I think this is going to be it.
Just give him the rig. No, no, no, no, no.
That talk makes me nervous
through the eagles.
The Eagles got gotta fucking horrific,
horrifically terrifying
fucking running game. And uh,
nick folds is not a backup quarterback
that as a starting quarterback who lost
his fucking job and he's coming
back like a fucking revenge movie.
Did Defense looks,
looks fucking great.
And I don't think we would have done
to the vikings what they did. So, yeah,
I dunno.
I would say take the,
just trying to be humbled at
how to keep the gods happy.
Take the eagles and the
points. That's what, that's
what I would do with my money.
I'm not doing it. I Edelman's
out Gronk out a concussion. Um,
m and Dola had the game of his
fucking life. Did you hear that song?
The amygdala song? It's like
that song, Lola. Real. Oh Dude.
It's fucking Dijo la though.
Now they're playing nick fold
in the Super Bowl. That's fine.
It may not show or, all
right. Hey, Billy, Chris King.
I'm invited to a Superbowl party.
Don't worry.
Just dude's and nobody interested
in commercials or halftime shows.
Thank God and I am the
designated dessert maker. Uh,
you were talking about peach
cobbler on a Monday morning podcast,
but I can't quite remember if it was
a recent one or an old one. Anyway,
would you mind sharing your recipe with
me? Because I want to have the real deal.
I'm from Germany and can't figure
out if the recipes I find here.
Any good hope to hear from
you and go fuck yourself.
I just googled and looked at pictures
and then I found one that looked good was
this, this is what I
would say. I would say,
uh, I would say if the cinnamon, nutmeg,
whatever they tell you to fucking put in,
add more because they'll always be
like an eighth of a teaspoon a court.
They're going to make it taste good,
but they're not going to make it
taste great. So definitely be tasting.
You're filling that.
Don't be afraid to get a little,
a little heavy handed with some of the
spices, especially the cinnamon sugar.
A little bit of some butter in there.
And then I give it a little Dustin
before I closed the Pi of the Oh yeah,
you gotta it's gotta be a big
fucking delicious gooey mess. Um,
that's how I do it, dude. Everything's
gonna be all fucking baking.
I'm trying to get you all right.
Political relationship advice. Oh God.
Here we go. All right, let
me, I want to hear this one.
I literally unfollow people on Twitter
if all they do is talk politics,
unless you rationally kind of trash
on both sides. But like, you know,
if it's going to be like, you
know, so, uh, Trump just did this.
It's just say, all right. I will tell
you that. Well, I mean, yeah, I mean,
trauma slotted, Conan, Conan O'Brien and
the funniest fucking joke about Trump.
They go, how do you, uh,
Andall the whole Trump says,
what's the hardest part about the
Trump situation right now? He goes,
he goes trying to write a joke that's more
absurd than what's actually happening.
I like OEM Twitter,
like Trump on Twitter just is,
it's just considered normal now that
like a president has the time to,
I don't even like people
shit on me all the time.
I don't even get back to them watching
the quote leader of the free world or
just so, you know, that
wasn't a stain on my tie.
That was actually a presidential
seal there. All right.
Political relationship advice.
Hey Billy Willy Concoct,
I dunno what that means.
That's an, you know,
one with a little bit
of alliteration to pair.
Love the podcast and of
course the standup. Thank you.
You're the only comic that actually
makes me bust out laughing. Well,
I'll wait till you see Todd special.
So I'm a 21 year old guy and I've been
seeing this girl now for about nine
months. She's great. Treats
me good, loyal, and is pretty,
all of these relationship things.
They,
we start off like a horror movie where
that was all sunshine and everything.
I'm 21 prime of my life, I think a
darker ship. Everything's going great.
All right.
The main problem I have though
is she is a big democrat.
Big Democratic
problem is she's a big democratic
and he's a super conservative.
Uh, she's black and I'm almost
as white as you. Oh God.
This is like a fucking bad porno.
She gets upset when I post
political stuff on Facebook,
like pro a pro video of Trump,
but yet she posts all this stuff about
kneeling for flags and Obama is all that,
uh, yeah, dude, this, this relationship's
not going to fucking less. Uh,
she wouldn't even talk to me when I wore
a Trump shirt. Oh my God. Yeah. It's like,
dude,
like this,
this is a guy who like sort of saw how
the Nazis were baited into running over
somebody with a car going, well,
you know, this hatred on both sides.
Um, dude, I really wanted to side
with you, but you know, this is,
this is like astoundingly fucking like
I respect the fact that you like Trump
and all of that shit.
You want to wear his tee shirts,
but your confusion that she gets
upset is a little fucking weird.
Pisses me off.
But I don't want to ruin the whole
relationship over something as dumb as
politics that's too late.
So since you are already in an
interracial relationship and for,
and for a lot longer than me,
period. What's your advice?
Question Mark?
The lovely mia.
It's Nia with an end.
Um,
can tell me her 2 cents as well, even
though she'll just side with the chick.
Just kidding. Thanks. And is
always go fuck yourself. Ps,
Tom Brady's the greatest
of all time. Uh, sir. Um,
I gotta be honest with you, like, if you
don't understand why she is upset, um,
you'd have to try to put yourself in
her position and then read some of this
shit in some of his opinions,
I guess would be the best way to do it.
But I'm like,
you're not just a conservative if
you'll be like rocking the t shirt,
like you're all in. You know what
I mean? Like a bunch of words.
Girlfriend hates when I wear my
swastika tee shirt. Yeah. Not Nicki.
Do you think that's, it's
that bad? I mean, he has, he
hasn't run like, I mean, no,
I mean, no. Is he like, is
he like a Trump Hitler light?
What kind of booze would hit
was that at least gotta be like Moonshine.
So where's Trump Jaeger?
Jaeger bomb.
That's shitty. Bourbon going Schlog. Yeah,
he's like God, Lulu flakes instead of
gold flakes. Yeah. Johnny Walker red.
And there's, there's no,
there's no, yeah, there's no,
and uh,
I have a soft rake to fucking mix with it.
What's the worst when you were broken?
So what's the worst period of ahead?
Yeah,
college age.
Uh,
Milwaukee's best now worn that or natty
Boh national Bohemian was pretty damn
bed.
Oh,
you know what I always hated was
fucking a Bush light Bush light,
which I think Bush itself was just,
yeah, that was just like, yeah,
it was like water and then they wanted
that town. We used to east, I never,
you know,
something I never got into Pabst blue
ribbon because I resented the hipsters
that we're drinking them because it used
to be this blue collar beer that all
these fucking townies drank.
And then all these hipster people
wearing their a flannel shirts. Well,
you know those shirts for a while when
they were wearing like the gas station
shirt that had somebody else's name on it,
where they actually had to do the fucking
job and they funded some thrift shop.
Like my fantasy was that they ran
into the guy who owned the shirt.
They just walked up like, Hey,
I'm Jim, you know, as much. Oh,
I just feel ah, needed to shirt and then
he gets the shit kicked out of them.
But most of my fantasies are
violent. Um, my advice is,
uh, to, I dunno,
get a bunch of empathy. Uh, I don't know.
I don't, I don't see this thing working.
I just don't see it working. That's
going to be like the kids you guys are,
so if you're that far
away from each other,
you're not going to get
married and have kids.
Yeah. That's like you'd be fighting over
them politically too. Like, so what?
They're going to be Democrats or
conservatives when they grow up.
So that's a whole nother can of worms.
Yeah.
So enjoy banging her and uh,
I wasn't bossy lets you, while she likes
you and then I would fucking, yeah,
I would just be like, yeah, but
he's also 21. He doesn't know.
He genuinely seems like he doesn't
understand unless that was just, you know,
sometimes people just lie and they
write and crazy shit. All right.
Girlfriend drinks too much. Uh, dear bill,
I was hoping you get to help me out
with a problem I've been having.
I've been living with my
girlfriend for almost a year now.
We are in our mid to late twenties,
just for some background.
Everything's going great
except for one thing,
we worked regular nine to five type jobs,
which means most of the fun
we have is on the weekend.
And like most people we tend to lube up
on the liquor while we're out and about
or even just stay in and, well I don't
think anything wrong with drinking.
My girlfriend doesn't know her limits.
Often. She will drink way too much,
too early and ended up passing out or
throwing up though commonly both will
occur. Wow. Yeah. She doesn't know how to
drink. You got to pace yourself out there.
A few examples,
uh,
she will insist on watching a
movie after we've had a few drinks.
We finally decide,
uh,
we'll put it on and then after
15 minutes she passes out.
Then I'll have to stop because of
course I can't watch it without her.
Yeah. Well the teacher lesson
watched the whole movie and be like,
you missed a great one and
in the end the Butler did it.
It's a lay off the booze cause I'm going
to start fucking doing that to you. Um,
number two,
we went to a hockey game a few weeks
ago and when we got to the arena,
she ordered me a beer and
herself to double gin and tonics.
Oh my God, she has a problem. We had
already had a couple before arriving.
She then proceeded to down both of them
and 10 minutes before the puck drop and
passed out soon after
at a hockey game by God.
That's the fucking problem.
I had to drag her up to stand for the
anthem and again when they were honoring
the troops. This is fucking, this
is like a Kristen Wiig character.
Uh,
she then left for the washroom.
That's been one of my favorite scenes
though when she gets fucking wasted on the
plane and bridesmaids and she just,
when she goes, man, the fuck is,
and as he's walking out, uh, I
see then left for the washroom,
but came back with two more doubled gins,
a hotdog and a bag of popcorn,
which she spilled and blamed it on me.
Oh my God. That sounds like a episode
of intervention. Even if I did do it,
the first thing you're going to
do as snitch on me. All right.
That just took a left turn.
Uh, get the fuck outta here.
What's supposed to be a team,
but I digress. Sorry for
the rent. Uh, last weekend.
My God, these are all like bullet pointed.
By the way, in the Uber ride home,
she per preached, she proceeded to
whip out her tit to try and seduce me.
I told her to put it away because she
was in no condition and I didn't want to
fuck up my Uber rating
passes out. Wait what?
The passenger gets an Uber rainy
pass was getting ready to for the driver
that might have actually boosted is
ready. If the driver will look back
and saw as little sloppy today,
we fucking gin and tonic on
it. Uh, anyways, I'm going
to fuck up my Uber. A pet,
she passes out 30 seconds later in pukes
in the elevator on the way up to the
apartment.
It didn't make it a lot.
It didn't make a lot of a mess as she
was able to hold it back before I got her
to the toilet. Oh my. This guys just
truncate the piece de resistance.
Uh, she passed out during the bill
burrs show at the Sony Center. Uh,
how do you pass out for that create man
who just came in to entertain us? Uh,
just a pre face.
I had an allergic reaction that was toast.
Had a little bit of weed before the
show and I was able to be fully alert.
But yet you are the one that's
falling asleep. Jesus Christ.
This is like the fucking war and peace.
This is like Barfly,
uh, saying all this. However, I have
to admit that I'm no saint either.
I arguably drank much more than I or
liquid drink, much more than she does,
but I hold my boobs a
little better than she does.
I probably made her sound
worse than she actually is. He,
you get to take it all away, down,
raring to go back a little. Now.
You already been going to
look like a drunken mess.
Yeah, but in truth, she's a wonderful
girlfriend who cooks with Matt for me.
Leads to me is very beautiful.
Well in fucking live happily ever after,
which he's got three seats.
She's that puking on the
sheets and as you can tell,
is willing to come to a
hockey game with me. And yes,
she did buy me bill bird
tickets for my birthday.
She's a truly amazing person and
I planned to marry or someday,
but this is just getting out of
hand and I want my weekends back.
Can you do me a favor and turn that
light on my fucking eyes or a shot here?
The Sun's going down here. I'm not trying
to have a romantic podcast with you. Um,
uh, let's see here. I've had conversations
with her before and when she,
she's sober, she gets it, but it
doesn't stop her when she's drunk.
And she would get angry at me when I tell
her she's had enough and I can't stop
her from sneaking off to get
secret drinks with my money.
She feels bad and I honestly
feel guilty writing this.
You and she is truly amazing.
I feel like he wrote the first half and
then she walked into the room and is
looking over his shoulder.
Um,
but it's tough not only for me,
but I know this is not easy on her,
but some to her body sometimes as well.
I just wanted her to be all right and
for us to be able to have a good healthy
time.
I'm not quite sure what to do here.
Am I right to tell her that
she's got to take it easy,
particularly when we go out because
it seems to be working the way,
have to set a better example and
drink less, if at all. Yeah. I mean,
if she's a fucking booze
hound, maybe, uh, maybe both.
Maybe it both try to, uh,
drink a little bit less.
She might be one of those people,
you know, where once she has a kid,
she'll just fucking knock
all that shit off. Or
Oh God,
I could just drive around
with those completely where
she's a state has hammered
all the time.
Yeah. You'll have a drunken
baby, you know, coming out,
fucking stop emailing and Bill
Byrd started emailing, drew Pinsky
kid comes out dressed like foster,
um,
use it to do a fucking,
I love positive Brooks run the city
limits drunk comedian. Oh yeah.
It was fucking hilarious.
Yes.
And he uh, and he never
really drank. Yeah.
The way I know
he had it down to like to that that's
back when like being an alcoholic was
like,
funny,
this is how much I have to be careful
though is talking about all that drinking
made me want to drink.
Like I love it. I fucking,
I hate how it makes me feel though
now. So I kind of, I just lay off it.
That would,
Craig Craig Robinson didn't drink for
a year and then we just had drinks and
Arizona this past weekend. We felt like
trashed both mornings that we drink.
Oh yeah. And so he was like,
yeah, I thought I was back
after taking a year off.
I thought I was back when I'm a good old
drinking I think. And I was like, yeah,
man, I don't feel good either.
I had a headache every day.
It's an age thing, like it's
really, it's a young person
thing. Like it, it, it like,
but we had fun. We were down to
like, we would do those shows,
those theater shows and we would go to
like the cigar bars have a drink with
cigars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I still
like, I think what I'm, I,
my drinking maybe we'll be,
is like a,
this year when I go on the road,
I think like if I go off for three days,
like that Middle Day,
not the first night, because I traveled
and not the, not the night before,
I have to go to the airport, but just
that middle one, finding a good place.
Um, I dunno that, that might be the, uh,
that might be the way I'll do, do you
know what I went to last night? Oh my God,
I went to this fucking,
this eighties, like, uh,
all these bands, this crazy
fucking lineup was, or the,
the real bells was attribute Viv?
No, it was like two, two was,
uh, what was it? Uh,
like drama Rama and with them?
Holy Shit.
I think I can remember the song they
said, flock of seagulls, the Romantics,
they were all really their tone.
Loke oh my God.
Fucking the violent femmes Melly Mel
and the furious five for his file.
Uh, and boy George closed. No
way, dude. It was fucking, it was,
there was this, this was at,
uh, the Microsoft theater,
which used to be the Nokia.
Me and Neil went down there and, um, I,
it was fucking awesome,
but I learned a lot about show business
watching those p you could tell like who
is sick of singing their hits and who was
also like, fuck this, I'm bringing it.
And then I also learned, you
know, watching, you know,
he got to take care of yourself.
I have a story about that
because I swear to God, Dude,
if you see a band that let themselves go,
it's like depressing like us because
you love them and they look like shit.
And then all you're thinking,
it's like, oh my God, I'm all,
I'm fucking 20 years older than he
was when he put that song out. A fuck.
We're all gonna die.
But when you just see a band come out
and they kept themselves in shape and the
fucking killing it as much as they
older, it's, it's like, uh, like,
I'm not gonna name names, but I, I saw
one band that made me think like, dude,
I'm never drinking again.
And then I saw when I,
the violent femmes like,
dude,
they just came out and we're
just a fucking tight sick aspen.
Like I watched them, I was like, man, I
want to go play drums. I want to practice.
I want to get better.
Like there was nothing like negative
about watching the big just came out and
find, they flew, they went on up to
uh, uh, uh, Melly Mel and, and uh,
through his first five who fucking killed.
And you couldn't be more
of a different band.
Polar opposites like literally
at the stage would just turn
oh yeah, that's bad. As I did that,
the I heart radio music festival thing,
they have like the bandwidth,
the stages of rotate one 80,
and then they'd have the band and then
they'd do the set dressing behind and
then it would keep turning.
I this, I loved it. I loved it.
They get like a down in Anaheim,
they had it and like salt and pepper was
on in a couple of people do is fucking
nuts.
It was you just knocked out like 10 of
the bands that I should have seen back
then. And uh, you know, they all
sounded great though. It was just,
well I'll tell you off.
It was just one person that I looked
at and it was just like my God,
but he was still singing great.
But it's just like, fuck dude.
So we saw cameo like six months ago.
Uh,
I can't remember what it was like by
the water somewhere here in La and Roger
Troutman. I remember Roger Blackmun,
wasn't it? Yeah. What songs does he say?
Um, she's on a brick.
Oh yeah, house. Okay.
Uh, all those dude, he can't, you know,
cause he used to come out and like
leather chaps and a cup, you know,
it's like the coke spoon around his neck
to do it. He's still doing this. Like he,
he out with the belly. Oh,
not bad. Hips and knees.
And he's still wearing a company.
He was like his leather pants in the
back of look like a diaper and it,
and it would come out and he does like,
dude was a little,
I try to be sexy in a row,
swivel his hips up.
My wife has died lab and she was
like, he needs to fucking stop. Stop,
stop doing that. And companies, even
when you keep yourself in shape,
and he was not going,
he was,
but you got it. You can't do
that sexy shit. I'm telling you.
That is a self-involved baby boomer
thing that is being passed down like to
Madonna isn't un-fucking-believable
shame for her fucking age,
but when she starts twerking,
it's just,
ah Ha, what are you doing? Right?
Yeah.
And then it's like the older guy,
which you've got to do is you got to like
a isoc to Derosa about this. You know,
you got to dress like Dana
white when you get older, right?
Like Dana White is roughly my age.
Dana White, you know, he was a suit.
He wears to college. Shirt doesn't have
the title, it's a title rather than,
so he's a little bit relaxed, but he's
dressed like he doesn't look like a creek,
you know what I mean? But if he was
to show up, you know what I mean?
I'm not just putting it on him,
just saying that, that fucking look,
just so you take a guy the same age,
my fucking age,
and you're going to try to
fucking pull off like a tank top.
Like even like when you watch these,
these, those P90x things, right.
And the old guys are working at the 58
year old guys with the ABS. It's like,
dude,
amazing putting your fucking shirt on
because there's nothing they can do for
the loss of elasticity in
your fucking skin. Yeah.
You're decomposing in
front of me with Avocado.
They said you'd be sitting in
a giant fruit ball, a little,
little fruit flies flying around you.
So I learned a lot like guy watched,
uh,
those bands.
And it was the people that
we're comfortable with their
age and kept themselves
in shape and came out.
And what having a good fucking time.
It was just like, ah man,
this is fucking granular.
Would like you just were really excited.
But if they came out like you know,
they'd fucking this,
this still fucking
party and like you know,
Keith Richards back in the day and then
they come in and you're going to still
wear like leather and shit.
Um,
HD net have this concert series a
couple of years ago and there were,
so these commercials for the
concert series and they would show,
they showed Steppenwolf,
right. You don't know, you can,
God you love me.
Then again,
and then that middle section that goes
on for fucking ever maybe used to work in
a warehouse,
that whole fucking the psychedelic part,
it goes on for two.
Sorry I interrupted your story,
but there was so like them playing
concerts back in like the seventies and
there'll be jam packed arena
and people going crazy,
the crowd and then they show him now
like it was smashed cup from then to now.
Oh, now they're playing, I'm
like an outdoor stage and
tire audience.
Only about 300 people are sitting
on this lawn like lawn chairs.
And I'm like, I know cause
we're all too well. Yeah.
All the people that love it
back then are all now too.
So I'm just like watching people perform
at like the Eggers retirement community.
I know, but those guys have like 70 I
know it's fucking, I'm sure that guide,
the band still sounds
great and everything,
but then it's gotta be weird
having fun with it. Just like fuck,
we still have to make money.
I'm like, yeah. Well in a
lot of those guys they got,
they got so stolen from just completely
ripped off and then you add that if
somebody got divorced and shit, yeah,
you're going to be singing that song.
I just realized it cross my legs wearing
slippers in front of you. I'm sorry.
Those are greats liberal.
They are great slippers. No,
I finally bought some new
socks and I just want to,
I want him to try to keep a white
full one thing for you. I bought it.
That's why we're a black socks all that.
Well I can't wear black socks if I have
on like dark sneakers. Why not? I mean,
I can't wear white socks
with dark sneakers now.
I if I'm sorry if I'm white sneakers,
I need white socks. Really? Yeah,
I guess, yeah, I have mostly
white sneakers. No offense.
Um, no, but I think a lot of those guys
that, that's what ends up happening.
So I think the way to do it is,
and I haven't figured out
how to get into the game yet,
is you get to a certain point
when you're at the height of your,
your earning power,
I think you should already be planning
your graceful exit from this business
because it's so good.
So I think rather than going
out and buying flashy shit,
fucking hovercraft and all the
dumb shit that, that artists by,
by stuck buying rent, those man rental
units, I'm not buying a helicopter.
I'd love to, but I, I can't, uh,
I can't justify maintaining it to
fucking play this. I got a kid now, man,
I can't run smash cut.
Uh, thought that at the,
you know, what's cool is I'm doing Irvine
on Tuesday and Wednesday. You know,
that's like one of the other,
you know, it's like two hours
of traffic. Oh to, yeah,
I'm renting a little 22 [inaudible] Bob,
uh,
Bob go right over it and like 20
minutes. That was fucking awesome. It is.
Yeah. Oh my God, Dude. Fuck five.
I did my time. I did my time. Not
fucking do what it might be yet.
Another comedian talking
about how horrific the traffic
was during the first 10
minutes. How about I go up there and be
the comic who's in a good mood, right?
That's what people will come and outflows.
10 minute helicopter ride. Oh yeah.
That's fantastic.
I'll write up it fucking over it.
And this is the thing like to
look at the parking structure.
My land right on the roof of the
Improv now, um, we're trying to find,
you got to call up.
It's like I'm learning.
Every time you fly you learned something.
So I'm learning this time
is like they'll have this,
all these helipads so you can
even go beyond the airports.
Cause I was thinking like John
Wayne, he's, he's close by.
But then there's another
one that's even closer,
but then there's like these hella
pads on top of buildings and all work.
I'll just all around you.
But you have to,
you just have to call him and tell him you
go fly down to the solo. No, no, no, no,
no. I don't have confidence to fly
at night. I fly solo during the day,
but at night it's just a
whole different ball game.
And I'll never forget one night doing a
night flight. I was with an instructor.
And how you transitioned, uh,
the airspace at lax is he,
that you fly under, you're not
underneath it, but you, you're,
you're along the coastline or the plant
like a hundred feet off the water,
which is awesome and scary shit. Um, and,
or you fly over [inaudible] over like
those glow stick things at like, you know,
I think it's like a 2000, I'm only
done it once, like 2000 feet or above.
So at night we flew
over us over the supple,
that a one and you know,
it's fucking freaky because there's all
these jets coming in that if you're at
the same altitude altitude with t bone,
you said we're flying. I go, yeah man,
I go the cop a pig, that
endpoint, this is crazy.
And how big these planes are landing
here? And he just goes, yeah,
there's one right there.
And it was like almost underneath us.
But because when you're looking down and
there's not a lot of streetlights and
you just see the lights from the city,
I didn't see like a fucking, you know,
Ho seven 49,
seven 40 said whatever the fuck they fly
now I don't even know what the numbers
are anymore. It was like going right
underneath us and I was just like, wow,
you didn't see that? No,
but he did this the right,
this was when I was getting my license.
So I didn't know how to,
to look for Shit and everything.
So night flying isn't entirely,
entirely different games. So,
uh, I'll be flying down, um,
with one of my instructors. So, but
if it was, if it was like the, uh,
if it was the fucking summer time though,
but every time,
every time it's going to, by the end
of the show it's going to be dark out.
But that is a goal of mine
who I would love to fly solo.
Let me ask you this, how much does
it cost? It cost you to do that?
We'll fly down to, because you have to
have like rent the vehicle and pay it.
It's like 300 bucks. I mean it's
a, it's a decent amount of money,
but it's also like, it's not that bad
though. I use cover crops. We grow,
but no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, nothing
like that. It's like 300 bucks.
And then,
uh,
and it's fun and then I get another,
like I'll get like another,
I'm going to get another two hours
under my belt flying at night. And, uh,
I got this killer fucking
instructor right now.
My auto rotations are the best they've
ever been where they basically, so, uh,
we'll, we'll fly around now and
he just sorta like, he'll just,
I don't know what go,
you know,
engine failure and then you just have
to tick a fucking spot and you know,
you just,
I mean,
we don't take it all way down to the
ground and I land on somebody's fucking
front yard, but, um, I've learned so much.
I always had great instructors,
but this guy that I have now is,
it's really got my confidence
back up again where, um,
for me to go solo and everything would be,
you know,
I would have the confidence to do
it, but I like, but what's good is I,
I'm super fucking cautious. I'm
not one of those people, you know,
we're with the fucking nine oh two
one oh look on my face, you know,
show up with like a fucking scarf jurors.
No,
but there's a lot of people that get,
they get their,
they get their license and once they get
the license, they stopped the training.
And because it got it well cause they
know how to fly and then you know,
and then it just, they just
start flying around. Oh right.
So did you fly your parents? Yeah. Then
when they came out here and visit it.
But I also did that with like
an instructor and that was a,
well the impress their
parents blown away that uh,
they definitely day had a good time and
they're very conservative people. So,
you know,
sometimes you don't necessarily know
what they're thinking or going crazy.
They won't go crazy. They would just
like, that was nice. It was very, uh,
very in trouble.
I was exhilarated.
I heart is beating out of
my chest right now. Um, no,
my, my dad, uh, had a pilot's license has
a policy letter cause once you get it,
so like he held cover and no,
he had fixed wing.
So he knew a lot of the shit
that was going on. So, uh,
you know,
but my mother thought it was awesome.
She loved it and wasn't scared at all.
My Dad, I think because he had a license,
understood the probably more the
danger of it and that type of shit.
So he probably thought it was a little
squirrely when we were a hundred feet off
the fucking water flying on any, do
you know, the Jetson, whatever. But uh,
I tell you one of the great things that
I've done in my fucking adult life and
um, I don't know, but we're not here to
talk about make, we had to talk about you.
We've already done an hour and 15
minutes just like that. Uh, I can I,
can I come down the 90th day dude or
want nothing more than, okay, cool.
All right. Well some people, you
know, like me, I'd be like, no,
I don't want anybody to, nobody had
fucking know. So it's just one more thing
we're going to do. Like,
you know, I'm to, come on,
I'm going to be brought from off stage.
I have another comedian opening for me.
They've got an Frankie quiñones who
does the Cholo fit videos and he usually
towards the Craig and I.
And so I'm going to have someone
bring me on stage from offstage.
You got that fucking Woolies.
Oh yeah, I'll definitely do it.
I'll definitely do it. Yeah. Let me
just double check my schedule. I'm,
I'm 99% sure I'm in town, right?
February 11th, February 11th I,
Sunday Day. Yeah. What
have I got? I got reno,
I got Santa Barbara,
then it gets something at the Patrice
O'Neal benefit towards the end of month.
Oh Man. Um, that's right. I met Patrice
was mom and sister with you. That was,
that was fucking amazing. Oh yeah,
that was great. A lot of the best.
They're the best. Hey, so I'll, uh, I'll
tell you this, when you do sound check,
just make sure, speaking of
Patrice, cause I mean one time he,
he did some taping and the sound wasn't
right and when it came time for him to
do his taping, you know, they thought he
was a pain in the ass, but he was like,
the sound isn't right.
And he was like,
I want to be the loudest thing in
the room, so make sure your monitors,
so you know,
you got to just make sure that is right.
That's fucking right.
Then it's like, yeah,
you light saber is totally on
and you know, you know that deal.
If you get up there and you can't fucking
hear yourself and God knows when you
go to tape, there's always somebody
who fuck, something like that. Oh,
I thought it'd be good to just have
the sound way down, you know? Um,
just make sure all of that shits right
and then Gus go up there and kill it.
Yeah,
that's the plan.
I've never seen you so fucking nervous.
I'm not nervous. I'm just like,
I'm anxious and I know you are going
to be great if you doing it tonight,
I can tell this whole podcast.
Well also I don't want to be loved because
I know your daughter's leaving. Oh,
okay.
I don't know dude.
And I'm tired and a little bit hung over.
But other than that and a little bit,
yeah, I always want to like this.
Whenever I have one of those coming up,
I just feel like just for, can you
just bring me up now in my slippers?
So I just go out there and just fuck it.
Just do it.
The waiting is the worst part,
right? That's the worst. All right,
well that's the podcast, dude.
I'm so site and I can't wait.
I can't wait to see it and I can't wait
to promote the hell out of it and I
can't wait to see you finally getting
your name out there and everybody knowing
how fucking hilarious you
are in the world. Right.
We got four fucking kids. They're going
to be in college at some point. Right?
This one's already out of
college, so I know. It's great.
You got a nice spread there. A
24 to seven. Yeah. 24 to seven.
They go 24 seven. They're
all right, man. Todd,
rex, everybody once again
walking into the room. Yeah,
the satellite la.com for tickets.
Uh, definitely be tweeting this out.
Pretty sure.
February 11th it's a Sunday.
Seven 30 and nine 30 in
silver lake, Los Angeles. Uh,
it's the weekend after the
Superbowl. So, you know,
you can be all depressed at football
is over for another six months.
Come on out and see one of
the best comics. I know. All
right. That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in
on you on Thursday. You know. Gees.